ändere deine denkweise und schon ändert sich
dein leben. ich glaube das ist so ein satz den
hat jeder von uns schon mal von irgendeinem
angeblichen life coach vielleicht auf youtube
werbung oder co gehört. auch wenn es auf den ersten
blick meistens ein bisschen drüber wirkt und
man sich denkt noch nicht schon wieder so einer:
ein ganz kleines fünkchen wahrheit steckt ja aber
dann doch irgendwie drin. ich bin der überzeugung
wer das projekt mindset ändern langfristig und
richtig angeht der findet darin mit etwas
glück den schlüssel zum erfolg und zu einem
glücklicheren leben. hey ich bin isabelle
willkommen zurück auf meinem kanal. falls du
neu hier bist willkommen zu meinem kanal. auf
meinem kanal gibt es regelmäßig neue tipps
rund um social media aber auch ein bisschen
produktiveres arbeiten. heute möchte ich aber
noch mal ein ganz neues thema auf diesem kanal
vorstellen und zwar soll es darum gehen wie man
sein mindset ändern kann. das thema geht zwar
eher in richtung persönlichkeitsentwicklung ich
finde aber gerade wenn man selbst auf social media
unterwegs ist oder vielleicht auch selbstständig
ist dann sollte man sich mit diesem thema wirklich
mal auseinandersetzen. es kann einem nur helfen
besser in seine arbeit und besser in seiner person
zu werden. ich habe in den letzten monaten immer
mehr gemerkt wie viel eigentlich so die eigene
denkweise das eigene leben beeinflusst.  man kennt
ja wirklich nur seine eigenen gedanken hier oben.
für einen selbst ist das was hier oben jeden tag
passiert ja die realität. ich weiß ja nicht ob  mein gegenüber vielleicht ganz anders denkt
und denken für ihn völlig anders aussieht
oder anders stattfindet. ich glaube ich bin
persönlich jemand der sich sehr viele gedanken
auch oft viel zu viele gedanken macht und ich
merke das gerade immer wieder mit meinem freund
im vergleich weil wir einfach sehr verschiedene
denkweisen haben. gar nicht dass wir uns deswegen
irgendwie streiten oder so sondern dass mir das
einfach immer wieder die augen öffnet dafür dass
das was da oben vorgehen bei jedem völlig anders
ist. ich finde bei uns beiden ist zum beispiel
das absolute paradebeispiel dafür im flugzeug
sitzen und bald losfliegen. bei mir ist es dann
so bei mir gehen alle alarmglocken an weil ich
denke oh nein das flugzeug könnte abstürzen,
ich könnte heute an dem flugzeugabsturz sterben
und die chance ist zwar super gering aber dann ist
da noch irgendwo ein komisches geräusch und dann
ist's bei mir vorbei. bei mir ist die ganze zeit im
flieger einfach nur so ich bin angespannt und
nervös und denke darüber nach was passieren
könnte. mein freund hingegen denkt sich so: geil
die nächsten sechs stunden stört mich niemand.
ich bin nicht erreichbar auf meinem handy
kann drei filme hintereinander gucken sitz hier
gemütlich krieg noch essen. was gibt es besseres?
und ist völlig entspannt. wir sitzen ja wirklich
in ein und derselben situation in diesem flugzeug
und es ist ja wirklich nur unsere denkweise die
gerade ändert wie wir uns fühlen. eigentlich ist
die situation wirklich 1 zu 1 gleich und das war
für mich wirklich so ein punkt wo ich gesagt
habe okay vielleicht sollte ich mal ein bisschen
daran arbeiten mein mindset zu ändern. seitdem
beschäftige ich mich doch irgendwie mehr und mehr
mit diesem thema und merke immer mehr das es was
ist was wirklich jedem gut tun würde das
zu tun. fange ich mal mit dem an was definitiv an
erster stelle dieser reise der mindset änderung
stehen sollte und zwar solltest du bei dir selbst
anfangen. nimm dir doch wirklich einfach mal zeit
und beschäftige dich gerade aktuell im lockdown
geht es wirklich gut beschäftige dich einfach mal
mit dir selbst. was sind deine ziele? warum möchtest
du eigentlich bestimmte dinge? warum magst du
bestimmte dinge nicht? hinterfragt einfach mal
wirklich so ein bisschen wer du eigentlich bist
wohin du eigentlich willst. wie du das eigentlich
willst. all sowas um dir einfach mal bewusst zu werden
wer du eigentlich bist. ich persönlich finde dass
das gerade so in den 20er jahren also ich bin
gerade 25 sehr verloren geht. man ist irgendwie
so in einer einstellung go go go: ich treffe
mich mit freunden dann mach ich das und dann reise ich
und dann verwirkliche ich mich selbst indem ich work and travel jahr mach.
momentan geht
es natürlich eingeschränkt durch Corona.
aber all sowas hält einen irgendwie total davon ab
sich mal wirklich mit sich selbst zu beschäftigen
und auch mal zur ruhe zu kommen und sich wirklich
zeit dafür zu nehmen. ein guter alter tipp den man
aber in zeiten von handy social media ipad laptop
und co zu selten berücksichtigt ist es sich
einfach mal über das thema zu belesen. mir
hat es im letzten jahr absolut geholfen einfach mal
wieder ein buch in die hand zu nehmen. ich muss
sagen die letzten jahre davor ist mein lesen doch
irgendwie sehr in den hintergrund geraten. ich bin
aber sehr froh dass ich das mittlerweile wieder
sehr regelmäßig mache weil es einem gerade bei
einem thema wie mindset ändern doch sehr viel helfen
kann. man sollte auch einfach mal anfangen chancen
zu erkennen. so oft steht man vor herausforderungen
und denkt jetzt muss ich das noch machen und
warum kam denn jetzt schon wieder das? und jetzt
habe ich schon wieder eine neue herausforderung.
versuch doch einfach wenn dir das nächste mal
irgendwo eine herausforderung begegnet das ganze
ein bisschen anders zu sehen und denk darüber
nach dass das ja eine ziemlich coole chance ist
und selbst wenn du vielleicht fehler machst oder
das ganze nicht schaffst dann weißt du danach
trotzdem mehr weil man ja bekanntlich aus den
fehlern lernt. ich versuche mir darauf immer zu
denken wenn ich diese herausforderung annehme und mich dieser chance widme dann bin ich schon
zu 90 prozent weiter als die meisten menschen
weil die meisten menschen herausforderungen
sehen und denken na also herausforderungen dasist
negativ das mache ich nicht das lasse ich
da bleibe ich lieber bei dem wie es schon immer
ist. wann hast du eigentlich das letzte mal
deine komfortzone verlassen? bei mir war das
definitiv der schritt in die selbstständigkeit
den ich letztes jahr gewagt habe. ich denke einfach
immer wer nichts wagt der nicht gewinnt und es ist
einfach wirklich so. man hat so viele momente
im leben wo man vielleicht spontan irgendwas
neues gewagt hat und daraus haben sich so coole
dinge ergeben und dann denkt man zurück und denkt
hätte ich diesen schritt nicht gemacht dann wäre
das jetzt alles nicht passiert. ich persönlich
sitzt einfach lieber irgendwann irgendwo und
denke oh mann das war jetzt echt unnötig dass
ich das gemacht habe aber hey ich habe daraus
gelernt als dass ich mich frage was wäre wenn
ich das wohl gemacht hätte was hätte daraus werden
können. versuch doch einfach mal zu überlegen wie
du vielleicht auch im alltag deine komfortzone
verlassen kannst. es muss ja gar nicht immer so
was großes sein wie ich gehe jetzt alleine
auf reisen durch afrika. das kann ja auch ein
ganz kleines sein. versuch doch einfach mal klein
anzufangen und aber einfach ab und zu mal was zu
wagen was man sonst im alltag vielleicht nicht
tun würde. ich finde ein ganz wichtiger punkt
darin sein mindset zu ändern ist erst mal anzufangen
mehr an sich zu denken und das soll jetzt nicht
egoistisch klingen und man soll nicht jemand sein
der gesamte zeit 24/7 an sich
denkt aber ich persönlich bin zum beispiel so
ein absoluter people pleaser. bevor ich an
mich selbst denke denke ich an alle anderen. das
kann ja manchmal gut sein in den vielen momenten
des lebens ist das auch eine gute eigenschaft in
vielen vergisst man aber auch mal an sich selbst
zu denken und das ist dann auf dauer nicht ganz so
praktisch. daher finde ich ist es wirklich wichtig
am anfang wenn man sich mit dem thema mindset und
co beschäftigt sich auch bewusst zeit für sich
selbst zu nehmen und einfach man sich selbst sein
erster stelle zu stelle und überlegen was möchte
ich? wie möchte ich mein leben gestalten?wie soll
das aussehen? vielleicht auch mal nein
zu einer verabredung sagen wo man keinen bock
drauf hat weil man weiß eigentlich mache
ich das nur um der person einen gefallen zu tun und
stattdessen sich einfach mal mit sich selbst zu
beschäftigen. in dem schritt sollte man sich auch
glaube ich einfach mal wirklich bewusst machen das
es im grunde völlig egal ist was andere von
dir denken und du einfach wirklich dein ding
machen solltest. bei mir ist das zum beispiel
auch so ich mache schon seit meinem teenie-alter
youtube und es war immer wieder so ein punkt
wo ich wusste dass andere leute hinter meinem
rücken gerade damals in der schule darüber reden
und es war immer so in meinem hinterkopf:  dieses
aber anderen gefällt das nicht was nicht mache
aber damals hatte ich so viel bock darauf dass
mir das völlig egal war. irgendwann in den jahren
ist das ein bisschen verschwunden und ich habe
mir mehr gedanken darüber gemacht als ich hätte
machen sollen. gerade ist aber so eine phase wo
ich wirklich wieder denk ist mir völlig egal ob
andere was sagen. ich find's einfach cool mir bringts
spaß. deswegen mache ichs. das ist glaube ich
genau die denkweise die man in viel viel mehr
bereichen jeden tag in verschiedenen momenten
des lebens haben sollte. sein mindset ändert man
natürlich auch nicht von heute auf morgen. das
ist wirklich etwas wo man einfach regelmäßig
im alltag immer wieder daran denken muss. da
hilft auch wirklich regelmäßig bücher zu dem
thema lesen weil ich glaube jeder von uns
kennt das dass man richtig inspirierendes oder
motivierendes buch gelesen hat oder vielleicht
ein inspirierendes youtube video gesehen hat und
danach so denkt also jetzt ärmel hoch ich krämpel
mein ganzes leben um. ab morgen bin ich
der perfekte mensch. meistens hält diese motivation
ein zwei tage und danach ist man wieder in seinem
alltagstrott gefangen und es geht irgendwie
einfach so verloren. da hilft es einfach
wirklich wenn du regelmäßig dich mit dem thema
beschäftigst. ich habe zum beispiel schon mal ein
video darüber gemacht dass ich auch für meine
gesamte private lebensplanung und meine gesamten
ideen und so wie ich mein leben gern leben möchte
dafür nutze ich auch die app notion. da verlinke ich
dir hier oben nochmal ein video. da kannst du
dir das noch mal genauer angucken. ich versuche
einfach mich regelmäßig mit den notizen die ich
darin so sammel über mein leben & co mich damit
zu beschäftigen und das immer weiterzuentwickeln.
mich vielleicht einer neuen frage zu widmen die
ich über mich selbst beantworten möchte. und wenn
man das einfach regelmäßig macht und versucht in
seinen alltag zu integrieren vielleicht auch
irgendwann seine routine dann wird es auch mit
der zeit. du musst auch wirklich einfach mal
anfangen mehr an dich zu glauben. ich glaube
jeder von uns kennt das dass man denkt man ist
nicht gut genug man kann das doch nicht so gut
wie andere. man muss aber einfach wirklich
anfangen überzeugt von sich selber zu sein und
dann merkt man wie überzeugt andere plötzlich
auch von einem sind. ich habe auch mal in einem buch
gelesen dass man immer nur einen wer braucht. ich
fand das super spannend weil es quasi gezeigt hat
dass egal was du machen möchtest es gibt fast
immer wen der es schon geschafft hat und
das heißt du hast auch immer quasi einen wer der
dir zeigen könnte wie das geht. bei mir persönlich
ist es mittlerweile echt so dass jedes mal wenn
ich ner neuen herausforderung oder chance begegne
denke ich mittlerweile so ach ganz ehrlich das
haben auch schon andere geschafft die haben auch
bei null angefangen warum soll ich das nicht
auch schaffen? und wenn ich denke okay vielleicht
schaff ich das nicht alleine und dann denke ich
da ja dann suche ich mir halt wen der das schon
geschafft hat und frag ihn oder schreibe
ich dem ne mail auch wenn ich den nicht kenne.
vielleicht hilft er mir ja. versuch also einfach
mal nicht immer zu denken oh nee das kann ich
sowieso nicht und das überlass ich lieber
anderen sondern dent einfach mal hey wenn andere
das schaffen schaff ich das ja wohl auch! ich
hoffe diese ersten schritte können dir wirklich
dabei helfen auf die reise der mindset änderung
dich zu begeben. wenn dir das video gefallen hat
und du in nächster zeit keine neuen videos von mir
verpassen möchtest dann abonniere doch gerne meinen
kanal.  ansonsten findest du hier jetzt an der
seite auch noch die ein oder andere inspiration
für weitere videos von mir und dann sehen wir uns
hoffentlich im nächsten video wieder bis dahin